hi there steve kaufman here
um i'm leaving uh
for croatia on thursday with my wife
uh
and uh for the last week i've been
studying cerebral croatian we have the
serbian many stories at link
and so i've been at it for a week
and
i'm going to try to speak obviously when
i'm in croatia
i'm going to try to understand
that's why i'm trying to learn as much
of the language as i can in this short
period of time because it'll make my
stay there
more interesting more pleasant
i don't know how much i'll be able to do
so as i'm doing this i i sort of
realized that that because this i'm not
i don't want to be you know a perfect
speaker of cerebral croatian
i just want to communicate and
understand some things
and so i realized that i'm not really
focused in on trying to nail the
case endings or or any of this other
stuff
you know the uh the difficulties of
slavic languages uh aspects of verbs and
verbs of motion i'm aware of these
things
and and i realized that that my
willingness to not be preoccupied with
these points of grammar
is very much going to help me
engage more with the language and i
realize that this doesn't just apply to
sort of a brief fling at
serbo croatian here i think it applies
generally
i remember in learning german when i
stopped trying to ace the declension
tables i actually spoke more got into
the language
the more you get into the language
the more you listen and read and speak
and just engage with the language
without second thoughts or doubts about
the grammar
the better you're going to do
and that doesn't mean i ignore the
grammar
uh you know obviously i want to get a
bit of an overview
although there isn't that much there are
a few things in croatian that seem
different but you come across them
anyway
um for example one of the interesting
things in serbo croatian is that they
have the same pattern as i found in
romanian and greek you know in other
words if i want to
go or you know jelly
or whatever like the uh the the second
verb i want to go the second verb is not
in the infinitive i don't know if it's
in a subjective or what it's in but it's
the same person so
felon milo in greek i want to speak or
melissa fel felona or
vrausavorbesque in romanian it seems to
be a pattern in the balkans that that
when you want to do something or or
wherever you have one word following
another they don't use the infinitive
which is kind of interesting
in russian they don't do that in the
other slavic languages but
a lot of these sort of grammatical
patterns because i'm listening so much
actually i should have checked how many
times i've listened
but uh in one in in essentially a week
because i started last monday
uh i have i did check my stats there
that i have listened i think it is 18
hours
no eight hours sorry eight and a half
hours
of croatian
or serbo croatian i know some 2000 words
i've gone through the many stories i'm
going through them a second time third
time fourth i'm reading and i begin
typically by just going through the
flash cards like if there's 12 yellow
words in the lesson i go through them
knock that
down to
four because i know most of them by now
and then i read through the story again
so i go through the stories i'm on my
second pass here in reading and about 26
because i've been through them once but
i've listened to them many many many
times so when you listen
then without really worrying about the
grammar
certain phrases like i mentioned you
know jealous
or
whatever it might be so that pattern
seems to appear quite often and i notice
it or uh you know often said kokuchi
kokucha is at home
so in russian doma you're not saying
russia damoi is like you're going home
doma is your at home so kadkuche is at
home
ichikuchi
is to go home
so you start to pick up on these phrases
which embody the ending without having
to
worry about
uh
the the declension table
i've become aware that in
serbo-croatian it seems like in the
plural
the instrumental and the data seem to
blend into one
form
and every time i listen i try to notice
these things
and that's the tremendous advantage of
the mini stories is that i know the
stories i'm listening through to try and
focus in on some of the patterns to try
to get those into my brain
as patterns as phrases
rather than as the result of me
reconstructing a sentence based on what
i know about the grammar
now you can only do that so often then
it becomes boring so i've also
downloaded this book
uh
bridge on the drena
i think it's
priya
uh
i can't remember anyway very difficult
like i'm looking up every second word or
more uh but it and i have the audiobook
for that so i'm listening to that and
i'm hoping that in time i'll be able to
understand some of it when i listen to
it but it's also a break from
the stories
it's obviously very difficult and
challenging so that when i go back to
the stories it's fresh again it's easy
it's pleasing and i'm focusing in on the
phrases but i'm not trying to ace the
grammar and so when i am in croatia and
and bosnia to the extent that i'll be
engaged with people and speaking and
trying to understand what they're saying
i'm not going to worry about how my case
has come out uh it was the same when i
was in ukraine speaking russian and
ukrainian i was even on television
apparently i make lots of mistakes it
didn't bother me i was quite capable of
understanding what people were saying
and i was able to express myself
and
i guess i'm beginning to think more and
more first of all as i i said in in
montreal i think we're in this new age
of language learning which should be
more of a
polyglot experience where we can learn
more languages not necessarily one to
perfection although if that's what
someone wants to do
go for it legitimate aspiration no doubt
but i know lots of people who speak
very fluid english
and who are not dramatically correct we
have an employee who is a programmer
he's russian
he speaks very good english he can
explain things he's great in dealing
with our users this is on the wood
product side
getting their
needs and then he converts it into
software but he communicates very very
well but to him articles are optional
you know sometimes he hits the article
sometimes he doesn't it doesn't bother
him it doesn't inhibit him from
communicating
yeah articles don't exist in russian so
no amount of explanation is going to
make it
meaningful you know he can't be thinking
of rules every time he's speaking about
whether there's an article there or not
either he develops that habit or he
doesn't uh the same with the famous
third person singular of the present
tense in english so many people leave
off the s even though they know it's
required there it's because for whatever
reason they haven't developed that habit
so
my advice on grammar
first of all i think people should learn
more than one language i'm increasingly
convinced of that i think it helps us in
all of our language learning
plus it enables us to discover new
languages and if we're going to do that
then we're going to have to accept
less than perfect results
and be less obsessed with achieving
perfection now this is perhaps not such
good advice if you need say english for
your work and your corresponding but
even in english i have talked with
people in europe in japan in english and
they make mistakes regularly and yet
the english works for them wonderfully
they understand and they get their
meaning across so i think we can
gradually get better at grammar the more
we
involve ourselves with the language the
more listening and reading the more
speaking the more engaged we are with
the language gradually we
more and more of the phrasing will
become natural to us without us having
to think about why
and and
in many ways an obsession with the
grammar holds us back inhibits us
we're worried we're uncertain we think
what stephen crashing calls the
effective filter so in language learning
you want as much as possible to get into
your brain you want to engage with the
language as much as possible and you
want to minimize interference
inhibitions frustrations fears so to
that extent i say take it easy on
grammar don't ignore grammar if you are
curious look something up by all means
but don't expect that you're going to
nail it down expect that you will
continue to make mistakes for quite a
while and only gradually improve so to
improve in your language accuracy go
easy on grammar bye for now
you